Donald Trump had his first call as
president with this guy he hasn't made a
lot of news lately but he's the Russian
leader his named Vladimir Putin you
might have heard of him and according to
US officials with knowledge of the call
sit down for this folks Donald Trump
denounced a treaty called New START
which caps US and Russian deployment of
nuclear warheads he denounced it as a
bad deal for the United States but what
has been revealed is that when Vladimir
Putin raised the possibility of
extending the 2010 deal
Trump paused the phone call to ask his
aides what the deal actually is then he
got back on the phone and said to Putin
yeah that's one of those bad Obama deals
that were going to get rid of what's new
start all Obama did it Vladimir terrible
deal we're going to get rid of it
reportedly Donald Trump also talked
about Amir Putin about his own popular
during the phone call the White House
has declined to comment for people who
aren't too familiar with the New START
deal it gives the US and Russia until
February of 2018 to reduce the number of
deployed strategic nuclear warheads to
no more than fifteen hundred and fifty
which might sound high more than enough
to destroy the planet but still the
smallest number that the countries would
have had in decades and you might
remember that during a 2016 debate
Donald Trump said that Russia had
outsmarted the United States which would
the treaty which instead of calling it
by its actual name you start he called
the start up but what difference does it
make the trumpets don't care he also
asserted incorrectly then that the deal
allowed Russia to continue to produce
nuclear warheads while the US could not
that's also not true also continuing the
mixed signals between Trump and his
cabinet Secretary of State Rex Tillerson
said that he actually supports the New
START deal he said that during his
Senate confirmation hearings I'm
starting to put some weight behind Pat
the assertions that Donald Trump might
not be adequately preparing for some of
these phone calls probably not and I
mean just to be clear so he was against
the New START treaty because Obama was
the person that initiated it yeah I mean
the original strategic arms reduction
treaty was proposed by Ronald Reagan and
they're signed by George HW Bush both
Republican presidents would he be
against that one too who even knows I
mean it's completely unprecedented elle'
phone call with a foreign leader the
president gets an in-depth briefing
paper I know you're probably already
saying wait wait a second in-depth
briefing paper and Donald Trump doesn't
make any sense of course it doesn't
Trump doesn't lead we initially thought
that he would accept a single page of
double-spaced bullet points which would
work out to like eight to ten bullet
points yesterday we learned that
actually that's too much he now wants a
single page that is mostly pictures like
basically the picture book equivalent of
the presidency with only like three to
four bullet points and you obviously are
not going to be well prepared for a
phone call if that's your preparation
strategy I would love to see what it
says on those bullet points I mean is
the first one Vladimir Putin is the
president of Russia on to the next one
you probably should be briefing him at
that level yeah I don't think that
that's the I mean I know it sounds crazy
but you probably need to be talking to
Trump like that and the bigger picture
concern here is that Donald Trump saying
he's against New START sort of de facto
means that he wants more nuclear
proliferation which shouldn't come as a
surprise because Trump did say during
his campaign that he doesn't understand
why we don't use nukes more often
against our enemies and people voted for
him but remember people told Trump told
people and they believed that I guess
that he's like smart and my reaction now
is we should have elected someone with
like experience this is sort of what you
would expect to get and quite frankly
what you deserve to get when you elect
the guy who bragged about having bribed
politicians and sexually assaulted women
and he doesn't even know what the
nuclear triad is you get a guy who's got
to put a call on hold with Putin to say
hey guys what
treaty that Vladimir is talking about on
the phone absolutely pathetic and
embarrassing